according Moscow has begun hearing a new
criminal case against jailed Kremlin
critic Alexi navalny is facing several
new charges including creation of an
extremist organization and
rehabilitating Nazism navani says he
could face up to 3 30 years in prison
under the new charges well Legacy
novalny is a well-known Kremlin critic
and former Moscow mayor candidate he
became popular in Russia as the founder
of the anti-corruption fund it's an NGO
investigating the private wealth of
Russia's Elite in 2020 he was poisoned
with the narrow agent novoshock he was
in a coma for three weeks and it was
taken to Germany for five months of
treatment but navani returned to Moscow
he was arrested for embezzlement and
later fraud charges he's been in prison
for more than two years Moscow
designated his NGO an extremist
organization in 2021
moscow-based journalist Julia shop of
Oliver is joining us now what can we
expect to hear in the court today
right as far as we know the hearing has
already started and as of now Alexei
navalny is asking the authorities to let
his parents into the courtroom we also
know that about 40 media Representatives
have been allowed into the economy to
follow the process and law enforces
stepped up security measures near the
facility there journalists underwent a
thorough search and as expected at the
first meeting the prosecutor will
announce the indictment after which the
defendant will have the opportunity to
express their attitude to the charges so
Nevada is facing extremism charges right
now the hearing is not taking place here
in Moscow but in penal colony number six
in the vladima region some three hours
drive from Moscow to the east that's the
place where Alexander Burnley is serving
his nine-year prison sentence for fraud
and disrespect to court a few days
before the first hearing or on the case
the Press service of the Court told
journalists that no one would be allowed
directly into the Hall whether the trial
would take place but there should be
live broadcasts from the courtroom right
now and early in April the basmania
district court in Moscow limited
navalny's time to review the materials
of the case and he was given just 10
days to study
196 volumes of the criminal case so
basically that's what's going on right
now Nevada's been in prison for more
than two years he seems to be constantly
prosecuted why are they chasing after
him so much
together
well you know it's a complicated case
really many consider it a political case
as well as Alexei navalny is considered
a political prisoner of his
anti-corruption activities and uh for
his criticism of the Kremlin he was
arrested upon his return to Russia from
Germany where he had been undergoing
Rehabilitation after poisoning navalny
blames Russia for his poisoning he's
been in prison here since February 2021
and initially he was accused of Fraud
and was supposed to be released this
summer but
back in June 2022 another so-called
large-scale four-case verdict came into
force and now he's facing charges for
creating and leading an extremist
Community for his calls for rallies plus
there's another criminal case against
the opposition politician and activist
on on calls for terrorism and the
rehabilitation of Nazism so now indeed
he faces imprisonment for up to 30 is
Julia thank you very much indeed Julia
shop of Oliver's and been joining us
from Moscow